i feel
pretty under educated
have a pretty open mind which sometimes
can be painful on the internet because
people mock me or
you know you know if i say something
nuanced about communism
people people immediately kind of put
you in a bin or something like that
it hurts to be open-minded to say i
don't know
to ask the question why is uh
communism or marxism so problematic why
is capitalism problematic and so on
but let me nevertheless go into that
direction with you
uh maybe uh let's talk about capitalism
a little bit
how does objectivism compare relate
to the idea of capitalism well first we
have to define what capitalism is
because again
people use capitalism in all kinds of
ways and i know you had ray dalio
on on your show once i haven't i need to
listen to the episode episode
but ray has no clue what capitalism is
and that's that's
that's that's his big problem um so when
he when he says
the real problems today in capitalism
he's not talking about capitalism he's
talking about problems in the world
today and i agree with many of the
problems but they have nothing to do
with capitalism
um capitalism is this is is a social
political economic system in which
all property is privately owned and in
which the only role of government is the
protection of individual rights
i think it's the ideal system i think
it's the right system for the reasons we
talked about earlier it's a system that
leaves you as an individual
to pursue your values your life your
happiness
free of courage and force and if in and
you get to decide what happens to you
and i get to decide if to help you or
not right if you let's say you fall flat
on your face people always say well what
about the poor well if you if you care
about the poor help them
right just don't you know what do you
need a government for
you know i always ask audiences um okay
if if there's a if there's a poor kid
who can't afford to go to school and all
the schools are private because
capitalism is being instituted um and he
can't go to school would you be willing
to participate in a fund that that pays
for his education
every hand in the room goes up so what
do you need government for
just let's let's let's get all the money
together and pay for schooling
so the point is that what capitalism
does is leave individuals free to make
their own decisions
and as long as they're not violating
other people's rights
in other words as long as they're not
using coercion force
on other people then leave them alone
and and people are going to make
mistakes and people are going to screw
up their lives and people are going to
commit suicide people are going to do
terrible things to themselves that is
fundamentally their problem and if you
want to help
you under capitalism are free to help
it's
just the only thing that doesn't happen
on the capitalist is you don't get to
impose your will on other people
how's that a bad thing so the the
question then
is how does the implementation of
capitalism
uh deviate from its ideal
in practice i mean this is what is the
question with a lot of systems
is how does it start to then fail
so one thing maybe you can correct me or
inform me it seems like
information is very important like being
able to
uh make decisions to be free
you have to have access full access of
all the information you need
to make rational decisions no
that can't doesn't because it can be
right because none of us has
full access to all the information we
need
i mean what does that even mean and how
how big how how much of the scope do you
want here
let's just start there yeah so you need
you need to have access to information
so
one of the big criticisms of capitalism
is this asymmetrical information
the drug maker has more information
about the drug than the drug buyer
right pharmaceutical drugs true
it's a problem well i wonder if one can
think about an entrepreneur can think
about how to solve that problem see
i view any one of these challenges to
capitalism as an opportunity for
entrepreneur to make money
and they have the freedom to do it yeah
so imagine an entrepreneur steps in and
says
i will test all the drugs that drug
companies make
and i will provide you for a fee with
with the answer and how do i know he's
not he's not going to be corrupted well
there'll be other
ones and they'll compete and who am i to
tell which one of these is the right one
well it won't be you
really getting the information from them
it'll be your doctor
the doctors need that information so the
doctor who has some expertise in
medicine
will be evaluating which rating agency
to use to evaluate the drugs and which
ones then to recommend to you
so do we need an fda do we need a
government that siphons
all the information to one source that
does all the research
all the things and has a clear incentive
by the way not to approve drugs
there's nothing because they don't make
any money from it they
nobody pays them for the information
nobody pays them to be accurate they're
bureaucrats at the end of the day
and what is a bureaucrat what's the main
focus of a bureaucrat
even if they go in with the best of
intentions which i'm sure all the
scientists at the fda have the best of
intentions
what's their incentive the system builds
in this incentive
not to screw up because one drug gets
value
and does damage you lose your job
but if a hundred drugs that could cure
cancer tomorrow
don't ever get to market nobody's gonna
nobody's gonna come after you
yeah and you're saying that's not
that's not a mechanism and that's um
conducive the marketplace is competition
so if you won't approve the drug
if i still think it's possible i will
and it's not
zero one you see the other thing that
happens with the fda it's zero one it's
either proved it's not approved
oh it's a proof for this but it's not
approved for that but what if what if
what if a drug came out and and and you
said right you told the doctors
this drug in 10 of the cases
can cause patients an increased risk of
heart disease
you and your patients should we're not
we're not forcing you but you should
right it's your medical responsibility
to evaluate that and decide if the drug
is appropriate or not
why don't i get to make that choice if i
want to take on the 10 risk of heart
disease
so there was a drug and right now i
forget the name but it was a drug
against pain particularly for arthritic
pain and it worked
it reduced pain dramatically right and
some people tried everything and this
was the only drug that reduced their
pain
and it turned out that in 10 of the
cases
it it caused the elevated risk didn't
kill people
necessarily but it caused elevated risk
of heart disease
okay what did the fda do it banned the
drug
some people i know a lot of people who
said living with pain
is much worse than taking on a 10 risk
again probabilities right people don't
think in those times
10 risk of maybe getting heart disease
why don't i get to make that choice why
does some bureaucrat make that choice
for me
that's capitalism capitalism gives you
the choice not you as an ignorant person
you with your doctor and a whole
marketplace which is now created to
provide you with information
and think about think about a world
where we didn't have
all these regulations and controls the
the the
the amount of opportunities that would
exist
to create to provide information
to educate you about that information
would mushroom dramatically
you know bloomberg you know the
billionaire bloomberg you know how did
he make his money
he made his money by providing financial
information by creating this service
called bloomberg that
you buy a terminal and you get all this
amazing information and he was before
computers desktop computers i mean he
was very early on in that whole
computing revolution
but his focus was providing financial
information to professionals
and you hire a professional to manage
your money that's the way it's supposed
to be
you know do you have to have
so you as an individual cannot have all
the knowledge you need in medicine all
the knowledge you need in finance all
the knowledge you need in every aspect
of your life you can't do that
you have to delegate and you you hire a
doctor
now you should be able to figure out if
the doctor's good or not you should be
able to
ask doctors for reasons for why you have
to make the decision at the end but
that's why you have a doctor's where you
have a financial advisor that's where
you have
different people who you're delegating
certain aspects of your life too
but you want choices and what the
marketplace provides
is those choices
you